what's up welcome to simulation yeah
whoo yeah there's that excitement
there's that excitement we're gonna be
learning we're going to be learning
we're gonna get inspired we're gonna be
building the future with this amazing
knowledge we're going to be learning so
for all those who how many of you guys
have been a simulation before ok maybe
like 20 or so and then those who have
not where's your hands yeah okay this is
good new audience awesome
so simulation is rebirthing the public
intellectual and inspiring you to build
the future we do so by putting together
these multidisciplinary events and do a
daily show as well in our recording
studio on market and seventh Street
where we feature all different subjects
we're talking a AI and robotics we're
talking block Shannon cryptocurrency
biotech neuro tech geopolitics emotional
intelligence business we talk about it
all and we are hopefully gonna fill
sports stadiums one day that sounds fun
curious intellectuals for full day
events we super cool it's like twenty
two football players can do it so can a
bunch of curious intellectuals alright
yeah yeah let's make that happen it's
make that happen so we are blessed to be
at work wisest space there beautiful
co-working space here they're very
technologically literate they're
constantly figuring out how to maximize
the emotion of the space and the
intellect of the space and so without
further ado I want to bring Alan up for
a little bit founder of work wise to
speak about it and with giving round of
applause thank you and welcome to work
bytes everybody it's only through
partnerships but simulation people like
you guys we can really achieve what we
need to look what wise is all about
enabling the world to work wisely we
look at it a little differently a little
unconventionally we all know that the
world of work is changing we're all
seeing it we're all experiencing is
changing in so many different ways and
science is giving us some pretty
interesting insights that can be used to
just help us stay ahead of that change
help us stay ahead of the curve so what
do we actually know well we know that
it's not just about space no matter how
you design it or about collaborate it's
not just about technology it's not just
about interactions it's not just about
happiness it's about these and so much
more it's about empowering you
empowering every person and it's about
empowering your workplace and that's
what we call working wisely that's what
we're here to do so welcome guys welcome
everybody
soaking to hear what you got to say
tonight yeah perdy over to you Alan
awesome thank you so much our definitely
check them out were quite calm alright
so and now for the man of the hour we
have dr. David Eagleman joining us
neuroscientist author ajik professor at
Stanford an entrepreneur now of neo
sensory of brain check we have so much
to talk about look at all those books it
took me so damn long to read them and
there's one in the very back that's like
a collegiate level neuroscience book
that's taken me so it's so it's such a
really dense read I love it so much
let's give David Eagleman a huge round
of applause and welcome
[Applause]
hey hey good to see you good to see you
too
all right hey I want to say by the way I
have so many friends that I've seen here
tonight new friends old friends and all
the people I haven't yet met will be
future friends so nice to be here yeah
yeah it's it's a freaking pleasure David
you have no idea how inspirational you
are to me it's I'm just boozing with
neuroscience knowledge thanks to you and
it's it's so inspirational and I think
it I think a lot of us have gone just so
super inspired by you and it's it was so
difficult putting together the notes to
figure out where the hell to start with
you yeah there's a lot to unpack so
let's see how much we can do we'll we'll
open it up for Q&A after a fireside chat
so I want to start maybe just by
addressing a couple things that were you
know that we're on my mind about what I
learned from you and then I want to ask
you kind of like a first powerful
question so this this quote was at the
beginning of incognito man is equally
incapable of seeing the nothingness from
which he emerges and the Infinity in
which he is engulfed yeah that was Rene
Descartes
and I've always been fascinated by this
issue about the little strip perception
that we live on which is to say the way
we perceive the world has everything to
do with what is useful for us so we
receive a little tiny strip of the
electromagnetic spectrum we receive a
little tiny strip of hearing frequencies
that we can hear and so on things that
are useful for finding food and mates
and so on but you know what the last few
centuries have taught us is what's going
on in the world of let's say molecules
are quantum mechanics and atoms and so
on and at one end of the other end of
the scale you know
solar systems and galaxies in the cosmos
and it's very difficult for us as humans
to really understand the world and
either those skills even though that is
just as much the reality as ours is but
we just happened to be in this little
strip where we feel comfortable and and
we have to work really really hard to
understand reality at those scales so I
really love that quotation from
Descartes and then it's like humans are
right in the middle between the cosmic
perspective and the molecular atomic
perspective we're like smack in the
middle
you've right visible light spectrums all
we see just this tiny little fraction of
what actually exists all these cellphone
signals that are just going through you
every single moment there's so much more
though that I want to just even from the
beginning here you call yourself a
possibility
I've said is a student of the universe
you're you're looking for what could be
for what can be yeah essentially the
idea with pasta billion is amiss simply
just in a few sentences it's just that
you know our choice seems to be alway
coming to the world is okay you can buy
into a particular religious story or you
can do the thing where you say you know
science has got all the answers it's not
that I'm strict atheist and and when you
go to a bookstore you see books on both
of these sides but but I feel like as a
scientist I have to admit about the
limits of our certainty and uncertainty
and so my interest is in building out
the structure of the possibility space
instead of fighting and dying for one
particular story instead figuring out
like okay what what could be what are we
doing here what is going on and so you
know I to my mind that seems like a more
a more modern approach rather than
saying well I think this particular
deity exists because my parents told me
or I think we've got it all figured out
there's no more mystery in the cosmos
because every good scientist will tell
you that we don't understand even the
basics we don't know how consciousness
arises from pieces of parts we don't
know how life started all right the
origin of life on Earth you know we have
these stories like well maybe there was
lightning in that call
you know acids coming to place and then
you know and then they started doing
this thing in eventually got cells but
there's a whole narrative that we can
spin we don't know if that's you know so
one of my rep Jim Francis with that
panspermia exactly so one of my mentors
Francis Crick wrote a paper saying you
know maybe maybe life here on earth was
seeded from somewhere else as in you
know an asteroid came in and there was
some life on the asteroid and so on we
can't even figure out how our solar
system evolved and produced life on
Earth because it's so difficult to go
back to understand how exactly and the
cool part is the job of sciences to you
know make steps forward and we do that
every year it's just that there's the
distance that we have to cover and the
distance that we're going to cover in
our lifetimes there's just a giant
difference there so you know so even at
the end of my life I know I will be
stuck with all of these uncharted waters
and so that's the idea was postured
billion ism is let's not fight and die
for a particular story but just try to
figure out what is possible and I just
want to say the job of science is to
rule things out and to open up new folds
in the possibility space that we hadn't
thought of before so it's not
possibilities is not anything goes there
anybody's story gets equal weight or
something it's just that everything gets
put on the wide you know science has a
wide table for accepting hypotheses when
we don't know what the right answer is
then you sat down with said guru as well
in a conversation and he's a mystic and
a yogi and the way that he speaks about
things is do it's different in a sense
is much more you know spiritually
inclined in that sense and these are
things that it's more difficult for
science to objectively quantify these
types of things and so being a
possibility that also that I'm not gonna
subscribe to a binary sort of thinking
I'm gonna find all this a nuance I'm
gonna find what all the possibility is
and I'm gonna keep exploring I'm gonna
keep exploring and I'm not a student
there's this this was this was quite
interesting for me in runaway species
kind of excited this thought process in
me that we are now in control of Earth
we're now in control of this rock and
we're a little bit more algorithmic
algorithmically advanced than other
species are
used to take 30 years to travel from New
York City to LA you would die on the way
and now it takes five hours in a plane
and if the plane is delayed we're like
oh I can't believe my planes delayed and
we kind of grown to these standards that
that you could talk to someone on the
other side of the earth a couple hundred
years ago now you can and if the video
chat or the Wi-Fi or data signals
failing a bit you're pissed off now as
we see ourselves in control of this
earth we have to figure out how to work
together we have to figure out how to
communicate more effectively how to
collaborate more effectively Oh inspire
the next generations of thinkers and
doers and kids and then the in in the
brain the idea of you sitting here right
now there will never be anybody else
quite like you ever and the general idea
is just that you specifically have had
all the interactions that you've had
from your birth until it until where you
are now family friends co-workers etc
and all these specific ways and there
will never be anybody else quite like
that and you you kind of paint this
picture of of going from Stardust to
evolution to your mother and father
their mother and father fought my father
and mother all the way down to you and
they all had to have sex successfully
successfully have sex to bring you into
this world today and yeah and when and
when when when you say you know what's
your name my name's Alan your brain
physically changes to remember that go
ahead
well sorry when you when you tell me
your name my brain changes exactly yeah
yeah yeah or so when you tell me David
my brain physically changes yeah yeah so
this is the thing your brain is changing
all the time that we don't know how to
build tech like this we build software
and hardware but my next book is called
live wired at which eyes
just the term live where for for what's
going on upstairs here because the it's
it's just it's costly reconfiguring
system every that's what learning and
memory is it's changes across these vast
seas of synapse the synapses are where
two neurons connect and you've got about
a thousand trillion of those and they
can have any strength between weak and
strong and so it's this whole pattern
that ends up determining all of your
memories who you think you are your
language everything about your culture
all that stuff is stored in there what's
weird is that we don't know how to read
that out and we probably won't for 100
or 200 years but it's not no it's not
random it's very presume it's
deterministic and it's extremely Markov
models are memoryless yeah good question
Markov models are memoryless and the
brain is just the opposite which is you
actually it the whole trick with
plasticity is that you're cementing in
particular States and and you're keeping
those so just as example if you can
remember the name of your fifth grade
teacher all these years later it's
because that state got put into place
and that's kept there and that's kept
there even while other things still
retain plasticity and they can still
move around it's it's it's live where I
mean we don't have we don't build things
like sit and by the way one of the
things about living in the valley is you
know kind of every day or so someone
says hey I've come up with this AI
company and it operates on the
principles that the brain does because
we have neurons and neurons are
connected by axons and we change the
synaptic and it's all [ __ ] because
it's not how the brain works because we
don't actually know but answer your
question about what is that that's the
whole point is we don't know yet we
can't build companies that operate on
those principles because we don't have
those yet that's what we're working on
and it's so fascinating the way that
neural architecture forms up until the
age of two
and then what happens afterward and this
whole selective process of whatever
inputs that you take in ossify solidify
and then other ones prune out and they
go away over time whichever ones you end
up prioritizing or D prioritizing yeah
yeah you don't want me to say what the
thing is is what why don't you go for it
oh it's what elves referred to is simply
that you're born of the fixed number of
neurons but they start connecting more
and more more so you get more synapse as
more connections between these things
and it gets denser and denser tilly
about two years old and then the trick
after that is a pruning of the garden
and you're actually just reducing you're
just losing synapses after that but but
nonetheless you get you know you get to
be an adult you know lots of stuff and
you remember all kinds of experiences
but it's a pruning but it's not what
gets added your brainy it's what gets
taken away that matters so yeah keep
going sorry that's exactly this and I
will touch on molding neural
architecture molding child development a
little bit later I want to make sure we
touch on this but you also you wrote as
many there are as many connections in a
cubic centimeter in brain as there are
stars in the Milky Way galaxy so just a
tiny little cubic centimeter and that's
a hundred billion two hundred billion
three hundred billion connections as
many stars as there are in the galaxy
and there's all this crazy way that you
know that we become who we become and
this is everything from the I want to
talk about these experiments cuz I think
these are things that we typically don't
really realize but and these aren't
sometimes there are not even experiments
there accidentals there was a the the
group of a hundred and seventy thousand
romanian or ret warf warf and children
and that was that was because of a
celibacy attacks that if you didn't
procreate they wanted to increase the
amount of population there if he didn't
procreate then you would get taxed and
they would go and make sure that your
procreating and so a lot of people had
too many kids that they couldn't feed
and take care of and then those kids
went into the orphanages and then they
were deprived before the age of two of
these important social connections and
important on just ways that they
cognitively develop and
then now we see a lot of the issues in
terms of their cognition and their
social ability and you wrote about this
and it was very fascinating there's
another example after this one hit but
do you what do you like yeah it's just
it's it's critically important that kids
get things like touch and speech and so
on babies get this because that's how
they essentially the human brain drops
into the world kind of half-baked unlike
other you know if you ever see a giraffe
get born or a cow or a dolphin or
whatever you know after 30 minutes
they're walking around or the dolphin is
swimming around and so but human babies
if you guys have ever seen one don't do
that after 30 minutes so the the the
question is why do humans take so long
to develop compared to every other
species yep and it's because of this
issue that we drop out half-baked and
that has really been the secret that's
led to our secret to our species success
because what we're able to do is absorb
the culture around us and specifically
absorb all the learnings that have
happened so far so an alligator now is
exactly like an alligator a million
years ago
there hasn't been sort of a building
alligator literature or science that's
that they can step out on top of but
that's what we get to do but anyway with
Romanian orphans it turned out that
there were too many and these orphanages
and so the thinking that they were being
helpful the people who worked there said
look don't pick them up and don't talk
to them because then they cry more when
you put them down so just don't don't
bother doing that and what happened is
this whole generation of children didn't
develop correctly they've got deep
cognitive problems so it's been one of
these you know mother nature's cruel
experiments where you get to see the
consequences of the sort of thing and
then there's another really insane of
the interesting example with whitman who
was just a normal guy cared about his
family cared about his work and then all
of a sudden was having a tumor press
against his amygdala in his brain that
caused him right this is biology that
caused him that caused him to go out and
murder his wife and his wife's mother
and then 13 people and just again this
is what
this is another whole weekend we'll
touch on some of the more freewill
determinism stuff but that just blows my
mind that you can just be pushed by a
tumor into could that kind of crazy you
lose control right so for those of you
don't know Charles Whitman was the guy
who almost exactly 50 years ago climbed
up the tower at the University of Texas
at Austin and did what was essentially
America's first mass shooting and he
murdered lots of people he murdered 16
and then 39 people were wounded and it
was just completely random act of
violence he was shooting pedestrians and
the people that came to help them and
ambulance drivers that came to help them
it was his horrible act and right and so
by the time the the deputies got to the
top of the tower we were able to kill
him immediately whatever wanted to know
is who is this kind it turned out the
interesting part of the story is that
Whitman wanted to know the same yes sir
he and he was extreme you know his high
IQ and articulate and he kept a diary
for a year before this monitoring and
describing the changes that he was
feeling in himself about how he was
becoming more and more angry he had this
angry and this aggression so he went to
a psychiatrist but this was a 1966 and
you know there was no brain scan or
anything like that and you know he talks
like ayat rest' he didn't get any
meaningful help there and so yeah he
monitored this whole thing and then he
wrote a suicide donors typewriter the
night before where he said when this is
all over I want an autopsy to be
performed and and that's exactly what
happened that's how they found the tumor
yeah and then the this this one as well
actually we can't say what other thing
please this is this is what leads to I
mean this is one story of a gajillion
stories that teach us that you are your
biology and when their biology changes
you change and of course when people go
and drink wine or you do drugs or you
are on prescription medications or
whatever the thing is that changes who
you are how you decide how you act and
and this is the sense in which we are
slaves to our biology and that's sort of
an interesting note but the where that
really matters is with the legal system
as we gain an increasing understanding
of this this really strains our
intuitive notions about okay well that
guy is guilty and and all I want is you
know bloodless it's totally natural we
just feel blood like we want to punish
someone who breaks the rules totally
natural and universal but as we come to
understand more and more about brain
function and all the ways that things go
wrong and the number of brains that can
be standing in front of the judges bench
like this guy's got schizophrenia this
guy's got the copy this guy's on drugs
this guy you know blah blah blah all
these things it complexify as the system
in a very interesting way and I think I
know the solution how we can solve that
but the you know what we have a lot here
is mandated sentencing where we say okay
look you committed this crime that's
five years and the idea is that pays off
dividends and fairness you're just
treating everybody the same but it
actually does not make sense to treat
everybody the same if all these brains
are unique and exactly because the
rehabilitative strategies that are
available are quite different for these
things and the recidivism rate I think
was seventy-seven percent go back within
five years yeah it totally depends on
the type of crime but yes on average
it's about that and orrible and we're
not doing a good enough job of figuring
it exactly because what we do in this
cut exactly what we do and pretty much
worldwide oh one more thing that the if
a judge right before lunch is giving out
parole you're less likely to get parole
than if the judge has eaten lunch then
you're more likely to get parole so the
rest is not okay the yes so it turns out
that and he spent a fourth of your time
doing neuro law yeah exactly so I run
the Center for science and law which has
a national law and profit yep I forgot
to mention that one it'd be good
predicated on predicated on this issue
yeah how do we actually improve the the
justice system and so by law org yes
i'll org as in science and law oh yeah
exactly so I'll just mention one thing
which is so simple which several
counties have done this now but only
when they run out of money to you know
they want to build a new prison their
prison is over stuff they just can't
figure out
as stuff all these prisoners in they
can't afford a new prison and so that's
when they start trying to think of
smarter ideas so the smarter idea that
several counties have done now is make
specialized court systems where we have
a mental health court where the judges
and juries have expertise in this kind
of thing they know what schizophrenia is
as opposed to by the way lots of jurors
say well that's [ __ ] I think he's
just making that up it's just an excuse
whatever sir you have expertise on on
mental illness and on the rehabilitative
strategies that are available you have
drug courts where they the judges and
juries know about I mean there are so
many rehabilitated strategies for drug
addiction from the pharmacological two
different neuroimaging techniques and
I'm working on and others and so you
don't have to take somebody who's in
there for two ounces of marijuana or
whatever the drug is and incarcerate
them and think that that's gonna somehow
do them good yeah and you were talking
about how the brain can actually over
time adapt in such fascinating ways
depending on what you're learning
um this example there's there's this
thing called the knowledge and that is
the like what is it it's 24,000 streets
and 50,000 places of interest that a
London taxi cab driver has to memorize
and they're studying this like three to
four hours per day of just like reciting
simulated routes of them them having to
drive and when you look at their brain
in neuroimaging you can see that their
hippocampus is larger yeah exactly
and this in the census is is a cool
example and it's no surprise which is to
say if you dedicate yourself to a
particular task we can very often see
physical changes in the structure of
your brain just as an example if you
take up juggling I can see changes in
your brain if actually if I look at a
brain I can tell whether you are a piano
player or a violin player just because
with a you know with violin you're using
detailed hand motions with one hand but
not the other with a piano using both
and that causes changes in the motor
cortex that I can just look at and see
so you have really big architectural
changes in the brain based on what you
and of course what your goals are and so
on there's some David when played
against a like a ten-year-old cup
stacker yeah the world champion world
champion cup stacker and and it's so
fascinating how the neuro neuro imaging
on the on the ten-year-old cup stacker
who was all unconsciously going on there
was basically no neural signatures in
his brain while he was doing this and
then David was basically consciously
trying to figure out how to cup stack
and and his brain was just firing a
crapload trying to figure out how to mop
- how to maximize it and this is the
general story is that when you're
consciously attending to something you
have to burn a lot of energy to figure
it out and what the brain is always
trying to do is automatic things that
you're doing over and over and figure
out how to burn it into the circuitry of
the brain so that then you can do it you
know quickly and efficiently oh man I
love this and no one like you guys ever
exists and no one like you will ever
exist again so interesting ok so you
have a theory it's called potato head
theory mm-hmm I love potato head theory
so the brain is caged inside of darkness
and the nose eyes ears just like a
potato head you just plug them on here
and then you're transmitting sensory
inputs and your trance you're coding it
and your brain is decoding and
understanding what the sensory input is
and so your idea with neo sensory is
that you can take someone that's deaf
this massive amount of people that are
that are hard of hearing on the planet
and you can augment their senses and
perception by putting on what you have
right now which is buzz which is this
wristband that you wear that has motors
on it or a vest which you're also
wearing that has motors on it
that vibrate with the pattern of the
voice or with the pattern of a dog
barking or someone knocking or or
someone that is smoke alarm going off
and and then that will give them greater
environmental awareness and so this is
your first entrepreneurial endeavor and
your quote to me was like
online was 120 scientific articles six
people can read them and understand them
but as an entrepreneur I have I can hit
a hundred and thirty million people that
are deaf across the world and that is
like the power of entrepreneurship and
having science marry itself with
entrepreneurship on the planet so ya
know your neo sensor you're wearing it
right now it's an amazing ever I was
blessed to go down in Palo Alto and see
it I loved it down there just gooing
again losing again with with feelings of
inspiration so yeah tell us more about
neurosensory and potato sensor yeah I
mean one of the things I by the way I
didn't say that always six people on the
planet could understand my papers
it's that always say don't find it
bother to read them and so that's the
hot so I want six people bother to read
yeah okay this is true slight speakers
in general and so yeah I mean because at
this point there are thirty thousand
papers coming out in the neuroscience
field every month and and it's totally
impossible to keep up with the
literature and so anyway right I
realized at some point that moving in
the entrepreneurial route would have a
much different kind of impact so right
what Alan said is you know because the
brain is locked in silence and darkness
inside the skull you know it doesn't
know where all these signals are coming
from all it knows is that it's received
these different patterns and it can
correlate them with other patterns and
that's how it puts together your
perception of the world so so as far as
you are concerned you're seeing you know
light and and color and and you're
hearing things and so on but inside your
brain it's all just spikes it's these
neurons these 86 billion neurons they're
just popping off and that's all that
happens and so what I really started
turning on about 10 years ago is this
issue of could you feed in a different
data source of information through a
different channel and the brain just
incorporates that into its senses and so
yeah that's what ended up that's what
caused us to build they say just what so
many of you've seen this before a bit
like
you know so this is for oh I'm sitting
on it wrong so I knocked the battery out
but I'll plug this back but yeah so we
built this vest with vibratory motors
all over it and the vest can translate
you know sound so this is picking up
sound here and it can translate that
into patterns of vibration can you don't
know if you're able to see through this
shirt here can you guys see that there
are lights turning on here okay if not
then I'll be wearing this afterwards but
anyway the point is sound is getting
turned into patterns of vibration all
over my torso and deaf people can come
to understand this and it's actually
quite easy and the reason is all your
inner ear is doing is capturing you know
capturing sound on the eardrum and then
the inner ear busts that into different
frequencies and sends it off to the
brain and patterns of spikes and that's
what we're doing here we're just
capturing sound breaking the frequencies
sending it to the brain in this case
through the skin and it's it's very easy
for the brain to figure out so one of
the things we do is we do science
experiments on day one on people the
very first time they're wearing this or
or the wristband is actually what we've
moved to it's a sexually it looks like
this and on day one people are really
good at being able to distinguish oh you
know okay was that the sound of a dog
barking or a baby crying a door slamming
or you know a siren or you know whatever
it is anyway people are really good at
that
so it's it's it's surprisingly intuitive
we've tested 597 people now with
deafness for various degree of hearing
loss and people really dig it
testimonials are profound and they make
you really realize that we are not going
to wait any longer for biology it's time
to figure out how to add these senses
substitute these senses augment these
senses yeah exactly and so that's why I
started the company in the our sensory
is is exactly for that so deafness is
our sort of it's our clear market path
because it's just it's it's a very
meaningful market for us to hit from a
business point of view it's a large
market also but the part I'm really
excited about is what comes next all the
things that we're doing next because you
can actually feed in any kind of data
stream and come to develop a direct
perceptual experience of that so we've
done things with draw
pilots for example where we're feeding
the pitch yaw roll heading an
orientation of the drone into the vest
we've done things with prosthetic legs
where you know somebody obviously you
can't feel your plus that I think so we
put pressure and angle sensors in and
then you can feel that and learn how to
walk well with it we're doing things
with artificial sense of smell you know
the reason you carry a smell dog around
when you're a DEA guy or something's
because dogs have really big snouts and
lots of smell and we have very pitiful
noses and so but it's easy enough to
build a molecular odor detector and hook
that up doing things with surgeons so
they can feel stuff while they're doing
an operation anyway we've got lots and
lots of projects going on the thing I'm
building right now which is sort of
secret but it doesn't much matter is is
multi spectral imaging which means being
able to see with detectors in two
different parts of the e/m spectrum so
you know infrared and ultraviolet but
also other more interesting parts of the
spectrum because honeybee see
ultraviolet and then rattlesnake see
infrared exactly right
but even ultraviolet infrared ranges are
huge there's all kinds of different
places you can see in it and so anyway I
just I want to walk around in other
parts of the spectrum besides just a
little visible light spectrum and and
the cool part is I probably mention this
yeah I think they're probably 25 Nobel
Prizes waiting to be found in different
parts of the spectrum because because
nobody I mean we have technologies to
imager but typically the only things
that people image are those things in a
laboratory yeah you take something in
you image it carefully whenever but what
nobody's done is walked around in the
world and just experience these
different parts of the spectrum while
they're walking around and say well
that's weird
yeah that's the that's the interesting
that's the next three years for me yeah
and there's a huge like you said
potential with potentially no Nobel
Prizes that can be given for those
things and actually us for ones that
aren't hard-of-hearing you can also
explore neo sensory recreationally and
we can do things like feel the feel
what's going on on Twitter on your body
yeah and some people definitely don't
want to do that
for many reasons but we did so they just
as improved principle we did an
automated sentiment analysis where you
look for a particular hashtag let's say
a very popular hashtag and then in every
moment we're looking at whether people
are saying good bad or neutral things
about it you can do these automated
sentiment analysis Trump for example you
get exactly on your body how the u.s. is
thinking or how the world is exactly
right any any hashtag you want to look
at you can say like oh good Oh bad you
know you figure out what's going on that
way so that was just a proven principle
there are much deeper levels that we can
go with that I just haven't found him
business case yes why we why we would do
that with Twitter but it was it was a
cool principle I think you know the
interesting for a politician it'd be
actually for a politician to give a
speech and in real time sort of feel how
its landing like oh yeah I'm being
televised to millions of people and as
I'm saying you know wow this this little
thing I'm saying about taxes not going
so uh that's thing I'm saying about this
is go real well yeah there's another
aspect to that that's super important
which is that when you're when you're
given the vest we're or the or the buzz
when you're given one of those two and
then you're you know you're learning you
have to learn how it works on your body
and how to and you start at a 50-50
accuracy because you're you're seeing
the word dog or cup and you you know you
feel it and then you go you click dog
and you were wrong and then next time
you just keep building and building on
that and after about a week of just
guessing until learning and learning and
learning and then all of a sudden you're
actually fluent in how something
vibrates and I can tell that you said
the word dog or I can tell you said the
word cup yeah it's actually it's it's
just what's introduced people get better
and better every day
but it's I just want to point out this
one interesting fact it's a linear
process as opposed to having a jump so
there's no moment where you suddenly a
better because that is actually the
signature of conscious learning as in oh
I've just figured it out but what's in
tahrir is it's all unconscious learning
because do copy it's actually exactly
the way that a baby learns how to use
her ears right a baby a baby does things
you know like babbles and vocalizes and
and the ears picking up on that and the
baby learns
you know how the year work so that's
exactly what we're doing here question
[Music]
let me let me tell you what I'm
describing the performance how well
people do on the task and and the reason
why it's linear is because it's a random
it's random over time well it's just
this is the signature of unconscious
learning is that you just get better and
better at something with that it's no
the point is it's linear it's not
exponential the point when you have a
con I want to spend more time on its but
when you have a conscious thing where
you go oh I get the trick then you have
this this jump in your performance and
that's what never happens so so okay I
really think this is important to cover
we asked this question I'd like as
trivia at the beginning by so how many
billions of neuronal cells are there
okay there's 86 billion and then I asked
the question well how many glial cells
are there because a glial cell has this
fascinating functionality in the brain
and we don't even we don't recognize it
so often people are only talking to
neurons neurons neurons but glial cells
are fascinating as well in my opinion so
and then the most recent literature that
I saw was 86 billion as well glial cells
and they have functionalities ranging
from maintaining homeostasis supplying
nutrients and oxygen holding the neurons
a place protecting them insulating them
destroying pathogens removing dead
neurons all true the reason people are
less interested in real cells is because
all of their signals are running at a
much slower level so the thing that's
interesting about neurons is they're
popping off these signals called spikes
they're a binary signal
it's like zeros and ones so neurons pop
off these spikes which travel it you
know several meters per second and a
given neuron will pop off like ten to a
hundred times per second so all of the
fasted for the rain it's all neurons so
if I throw a ball to you you catch it
all neurons so that's why people are
saying less interested in glial cells
although they're interesting for sort of
the long-term maintenance of things yes
and that
makes a lot of sense with neuronal cells
being at this why people care about them
more still exciting though to to explore
to provide the myelin sheath there's so
many other amazing aspects to it okay so
how about we talk about thought
origination this is interesting that by
the time that I become conscious of a
thought it I am already in the past
that's what the thought at t0 I only
become aware of it what is it half a
second later 500 milliseconds well let's
be careful so it's not necessarily a
thought but it's it's you're you know
like what happened so so I clap my hands
and I'm aware of the the sound and sight
and the feeling of it but yeah that's
already happened well in the past
because my visual system captures that
my somatosensory system feels it my
other person captures the sound of it
and all these things have you know even
though I mentioned that neurons run fast
they're not that fast so these things
have to move around and we've got
particularly big brains for our size
that's what makes our species really
special so these signals move around and
then they have to get all stitched
together in these multi sensory areas of
the brain saying oh there was some sound
or some site is some feeling and then
finally we say like oh I got it I just
heard a hand clap but it's already
happened a long time ago so the thing I
often say about this is it's like your
perception is you know it's like
Saturday Night Live which is not
actually live Saturday Night Live is
aired with a delay in case somebody
cusses or falls down she's like that and
so that's what your perceptual worlds
like you're living in the past when you
think the moment now occurs it's already
happened a long time ago and the reality
is just inside of our head is everything
that we're perceiving is just right
inside of us and so what I think which
is I have a hypothesis that I still
haven't figured out exactly how to prove
yet but I have a hypothesis that tall
people live farther in the past than
short people because you have to wait
for all the signals to get to your brain
so if you want to have a unified
perception for example if I touch my toe
in my nose at the same time the signals
from my toe get to my brain essentially
right away but from
so it has to thank you it has to climb
all the way up the spinal cord to to get
to your brain and that takes some
hundreds of milliseconds longer so if
you're really tall like my friend will
then then they have to he'll get that in
a minute in a minute so yeah anyway so
if you want to have a unified perception
if you hold my suit so I have a
hypothesis and I'm trying to figure out
how to hook up with like the zoo the
local zoo to test this because I think
elephants probably that's really far in
the past yes because if you touch an
elephant on the back of his foot you
know it's got a long way to travel to
get to the elephant's brain but like a
second or maybe oh it's not that long so
that it's probably probably 500
milliseconds okay but but for you know a
small creature like a bird or something
you touch it bang at you and you guys
noses if you try to swat a fly or
something they're a lot faster than you
are I mean they can see they can see the
slow human doing their thing fly away
they do it but but it's because I think
it's because their brains are so small
so the signals can get around okay fine
here's what to do and then it goes yeah
so yeah I think you know I'm actually my
next next book is about realities called
windows on reality that's about how all
these different creatures that we all
see realities so differently but I think
this is a really important point it's
about the size of the creature
experience is a different reality in
time which actually led me to think of
something random which is what if we do
discover life on other planets
eventually and might we find that
creatures live at different time scales
than we do for example like let's say
you discovered a planet of trees that's
a totally different time scale let's say
there let's say we conclude that they're
trees but in fact they're not trees they
just run upon a very different time
scale they're much slower or conversely
we find a planet full of super fast
creatures that move so fast we don't
even recognize anything's happening
where the tree creatures to them yeah
yeah and and you will be unpacking some
as well assume some sounds like up and
in some David goes through the 40
stories of the of basically simulations
and yeah and collectors I like the word
collectors they used in there
we would go through that I just want to
see what your thoughts are here about
where exactly and how exactly the
initial thought forms there's you know
there's all the experiments about I'm
wearing an EEG and I'm looking at a
button and then I move to hit the bun
but the bun turns red before I hit it
and the fact that I'm being red and the
buns changing the color is happening
faster than I can move to to hit the bun
so and there's there's other examples
like this as well and just like thought
originates and then we become aware of
it yeah I mean the general story is that
the the part of you that is conscious is
the smallest part of what's going on in
the brain and almost everything is run
under the hood and so yeah the the
general emerging lesson has been that
consciousness is the last time on the
ladder to get any information and and
this is the big question in the
neurosciences the way it's phrased is
does consciousness have efficacy by
which that means when I think something
consciously does that actually feedback
and change the thing about the system or
as consciousness and epiphenomena which
means it's just it's it's the last guy
to get the data and and it doesn't even
matter what it thinks because everything
is running and I think so that the
experiment said Allen's referring to
have to do with you know you can measure
often what somebody is going to do
before they do it just before they do it
so even though they think ok look yeah
I'm going to lift my finger at a time of
my choosing
ok now's the time of my own choosing but
in fact you can measure the brain the
buildup of signals that happen just
before that and you know so if you
answer you're watching a clock and you
say ok this is exactly the moment that I
decided to lift my finger in fact you
know from the from the EEG signal for
example that they decided a little bit
before their brain decided before they
did so this is an area that we don't
actually know the final answer to in
neuroscience but the question is do we
have free will question in the back yeah
from the from the tall guys so maybe
that old question yeah
give it a yell just shout shout shout
for now shout it over we have we have
whatever Mike go ahead there's a YPO
great I think I think the questions
something around what you're saying oh
I've got it now so it's a question we
had a little bit earlier when we're
talking about the the difference between
thank you the difference between your
subjective experience and then these
weird phenomenas that happen when it's
into subjective all that the thing about
this cool the collective experience and
I'm wondering how that fits into our
temporal frame because there's something
about those deep syncing on the
collective level to feel like they're in
a different temporal frame than in just
a purely subjective so in a way it feels
that I feel like there are people who
have who are very tuned to the feeling
of this whole room as opposed to me that
somewhere between the two I have a sense
of this whole room but I'm really
dominated by my own subjective
experience and I wonder whether there's
something around their temporal frame
which is different in the same ways
you're saying with the fly versus the
human if there a possibility that the
temporal frame could be different well
they're dealing with an inch of
subjective versus a subjective that's an
interesting question I would say there's
absolutely no data on that intuitively I
would say that probably the temporal
frame is just as slow and and what will
is referring to in part of the question
is is a completely wacky stupid idea
that I was talking about earlier today
which is just something thinking about
which is if if two people are having a
conversation they're really deep in
conversation let me back up one step
which is to say one of the things I
wrote at length about incognito is the
the way that your brain is a team of
rivals you've got all these different
neural networks that have different
drives they want different things and
and it's always a machine built of con
so you know if you put some chocolate
cake in front of me part of me wants to
eat it part of me doesn't want to you
that part of me feel socially bound not
to get up and you know go to get the
chocolate cake and you know sort out
where I might say okay I'll eat
chocolate but I'll promise to go to the
gym tomorrow or whatever you've got all
these competing voices okay so what I
was wondering is when two people are
engaged in deep conversation is they're
essentially now not just three pounds of
brain tissue but six pounds of brain
tissue and there's there's like a mega
brain that's connected by this very thin
bandwidth of communication but
nonetheless it's like one brain
especially if we're really in to
something together and the interest
objective that I was referring to is you
know like if there's a whole room of
people you know some people really
attuned to that and and this is just an
open question that of course I don't
know the answer to but you know is there
something like a collective hive mind a
collective hive mind of all these brains
and could that hive mind actually have
an unconscious by which I simply mean
it's aware of things that none of us as
individuals are aware of but you know
you need that sort of thing yeah so
anyway that's already so speculative but
interesting but I don't know if there's
a difference in the temporal this either
the frame of it yeah yeah that's that's
gonna be a good QA if we bring that up
again
so check so check this out here are some
things that we typically don't think
about if I'm if I'm holding a warm cup
of coffee and I'm asked about my
relationship with my mother I'm willing
I'm more likely to say that I have a
good relationship I'm holding a nice
coffee I'm more likely to say that it's
not so good if you smell something
that's follow when you're walking around
you're more likely to have like a lower
moral course your moral decisions are
sure moral decisions there's so many
things like this you just talked about
the argument that you have in your mind
about eating cake or not if you're
sleepy but have an important deadline so
there's all these sorts of things about
kind of the way that unconscious the
autonomic nervous system as well the way
that we blink the way that we breathe
these sort of functionalities that we
don't have to think about the way that
we walk it's really nice to not have to
think about every step
you take so and that there's a there's
like this is the CEO in the process and
that's the prefrontal cortex that's kind
of the conscious mind and then that's
observing and waiting for if there's
something that's thrown out of the out
of the blue and then it has to you know
reorganize and make sure that you go
ahead and yeah well yes the the
conscious mind
I assert is exists to arbitrate conflict
and so I actually suggest in the book
that this could if that's right it gives
us a way to measure conscience degrees
of consciousness among the animals in
the seventy of people always ask this
question like because my dog conscious
is my pet gerbil conscious and so on and
the tread the neuroscience used to me to
say okay well we know we're conscious
but the gerbil is not conscious or
something but but more recently it's
this idea that there's a spectrum and
maybe the gerbil is less sort of the
lower resolution consciousness like if
you take off your glasses at night
and you sort of squint maybe that's what
it's like to be the gerbil I go this is
good as bad but it's kind of low res we
don't know if any this is true I
actually what I'm writing about my next
book live wired is that I think probably
it's just a very different kind of
content as opposed to being on a
spectrum it's if you have different
senses and you're tapped into the
olfactory world or whatever it's fine
just very very different but so the idea
that I suggest though is that looking at
how well an animal can arbitrate
conflict might be a good measure of how
conscious it is just as an example if
you take a rat and you put cheese at the
end of a maze arm the rat will run
towards the cheese and you can put a
little harness on the rat measure how
hard he's pulling towards the cheese
okay now let's say you put an electric
shock at the end of the maze you can
pull you can measure how hard the rat
runs away and measure with a little
harness to the force with hoodies
pulling away so now let's say you put
cheese and electric shock there what
happens is the rat gets stuck running in
a circle at exactly the point in the
maze that you would predict from looking
at where the two forces cancel out in
other words the rat has two programs
running
times they go to the cheese run away
from the shock at the same time to get
too confused he can't arbitrate that
yeah um there's a bird called the
stickleback gull which it's like when he
can't pick that pair of jeans at the
store well but eventually you can write
as a human what about the rats there's
this bird that will anything if you give
it anything egg-shaped it will sit on it
and if you give it anything red it will
attack it and so if you give it a red
egg it will sit on it and attack it at
the same time because it just doesn't
have so anyway this is where I think
consciousness comes in is arbitrating
these separate votes in the brain I
wonder how many more examples there are
like that just wreaking blow our our
perception away this this so recently
I've been learning more about the
microbiome and microbiome is just this
crazy place of of bacterial cells forty
trillion of them more than there are
human cells more genetic expressions
than there are human expressions in the
body bacterial cells are billions of
years old human cells are less old and
just all this crazy information and just
thinking about how much the our
microbiome controls the decision to get
up and go get a banana or to pick a
banana over an apple or bag of chips
over either one of those two or when to
eat and all these other sorts of
thoughts so kind of all these different
variables tie in to where does thought
originate how does it microbiome play
into this and into yea the general story
is you know there's a huge the highway
of connections that goes back and forth
between the brain and the gut the vagus
nerve yeah exactly so you've got many
millions the neurons that are
communicating between these things we
don't actually know what this means yet
the general story you know the general
story is this the brain is the densest
representation of who you are and the
reason we know that is because when the
brain gets damaged that changes you in
ways that are big so like you know if I
lose my leg by stepping on an explosive
device or something I hit a prosthetic
like I'm really no different except for
the trauma of the event I'm not a
different person but if I damage a tiny
little chunk of brain tissue that can
change me entirely you know with a
stroke or a tumor or frantic brain
injury or whatever
that's how we know that this is a dense
representation of who you are as a
person then the question is what about
the immune system microbiome all these
things that communicate with this
hormones and so on the general stories I
see this is being like the main city
like this is New York City and this is
kind of the greater metropolitan area so
you know this does have an influence but
when you look at let's say the economy
of New York City or something it's
mostly taking place up here but there's
a little bit of influence of this other
stuff you know and then yeah you you've
made that point when you were looking
over the cityscape and you were
indicating that it is these are the
different networks Chinatown and and all
these different city centers but they
all work together as one massive really
exactly I was making a slightly
different algebraic my my television
showed the brain there's a scene where
I'm standing on a building overlooking a
city and I and I just pointing out the
issue there of this temptation that
people often have to say Oh where's the
spot in the brain for empathy for
generosity for whatever but the fact is
there is no single spot in the brain so
the point I was making there is you know
what if you looked at a city and you
said okay well where is the economy
located the answer is there there is no
spot in the city it's an emergent
property of all of the interactions in
the city and that's what essentially
everything interesting in the brain is
so that's why these are fools errands to
try to figure out okay what's the spot
in the brain for or film like we're like
taking out the port or taking out the
Chinatown or whatever it would be crazy
in this process of taking out the well
no so this is this is the thing that
happens is that sometimes so let's say
you you bombed a city and you you act
let's say you were a blind airplane
bomber and you bombed the the runway of
a city then you'd say hey I actually I
found the spot for the economy because
now there's no planes leaving the
economy is tanking so I must have found
that runway is the spot where the
economy is located but it's actually not
right
what's that brain would make a new bell
that's a separate point we'll get to
that in a second but that but the point
is this happens a lot with brain damage
where people will say oh we know the
area in the brain for blah
because when that area gets damaged you
lose blah but it's but it doesn't mean
that's where that's located even it just
means that that's the runway that you
need for all this other stuff to work
yeah
there's I want to talk about time and
time perception you fell off of a roof
was it like a ten-foot roof or so when
you love it 12-foot roof when you were
eight years old yeah and you had a
different perception of time and there
were there's so many other instances
like I've had my own scenarios like this
where time seemed to have slowed down
and I was able to take a long time to
make a calculated decision on how to
save my body from being injured
there's the wingsuit guy that was flying
down that that hit the rock and it felt
like such a long time for him to make
the decision of being able to pull his
parachute and still you know break his
leg and everything but still live so
it's a time and the way that time gets I
guess more if you do things that are
repetitive you do these this doesn't
this when we do things that are novel we
create new flows of connections and in
our mind so again it's like doing novel
things does something to tie there's
something to our perception of time as
well so yeah unpack your studying time
perception so interesting so yeah it
just very briefly right I was very
interested in since the time I fell off
the roof and and I got lots you know
over the years I collected lots of
reports from people who had said that
something seemed you've taken a long
time like a car accident or something
but I realize there was nothing in the
literature that had ever put this to the
test like do people actually see in slow
motion during a high-intensity event so
I ended up designing an experiment for
that they felt it took me eight months
to get approval for it and the but yeah
some of you know this experiment I
dropped people from 150 foot tall tower
in free fall backwards and they were
caught in a net below
they weren't caught in that going 70
miles an hour when they hit the net and
when I measured I built this device that
sent on the wrist that essentially
flashed information at them at a certain
rate and I could measure
how fast they were actually taking in
information and whether that change
whether people actually see in slow
motion during a life-threatening event
and by the way it's super terrifying I
did it three times myself to make sure
everything worked and it was equally as
terrifying all three times but the thing
is so what we found is that first of all
when we have people estimate with a
stopwatch afterwards okay how long did
it take you know picture from the time
you released to the time you land into
the net and then and then we also have
them watch other people drop and we have
them make an estimate about that too it
turns out that there's a big time
distortion you think that it was much
longer when you're remembering your own
event but the surprisingly we found is
that people were not able to see any
faster during this life-threatening
event their their speed of taking
information was exactly the same as
normal and what that led us to conclude
was that it's a trick of memory when
you're in a really scary event a part of
your brain called the amygdala kicks
online in a secure emergency control
center and you write down memories on
what's essentially a secondary memory
track you write down much denser
memories than normal so when you say
what does happen we just have one seven
you're now reading out much denser
footage then the normal normally we
don't remember much of anything your
memory is like a sieve where
everything's passing through so what
happens in an event like that is you
write all this down and that's a true
memory is for right when things are
intense that's when you want to write
down what's happening so when you read
it back out you're only your brains only
choice is to make the estimate if oh
that must have lasted longer because I
have this and that memory and I watched
the hood crumpled and the rearview
mirror fall off and that's the
expression on the other guy's face and
so on and so you end up concluding that
it must have run in slow motion but in
fact it's just a trick of memory and
there's so much more to understand about
time perception and hopefully we'll be
doing more studies and research in it
this was really interesting about the
way that the way that neuro degeneration
happens for certain people and it does
happen for others but they stay socially
active like nuns this was really
interesting that if you stay socially
active and you stay active just in
general with
things to do that you end up having less
effects of the neurodegeneration or
Alzheimer's on your on your brain but
the but if you're doing more of the if
you're retired and you're sitting around
and you're not doing these things
actively that was interesting your
you've built something called brain
check which rapidly mobili does mobile
neurocognitive testing which right now
there's no such thing as just being
having a doctor ping you and be like hey
like how's your attention doing how's
your short-term memory doing your focus
and so you've now been able to make this
which is really interesting yeah so we
use a tablet and we have these yeah you
just play these games for five minutes
but we're measuring 14 different things
about what's happening under the hood
and you know like cognition perception
decision-making us up again so yeah
we're able to detect things like the
decline into mild cognitive impairment
just in what sentence the issue is that
you know that's the stage before
dementia and that's the stage where all
the pharmaceuticals are useful and once
you're fully demented is too late but
but hardly anyone goes to the doctor
when they should it's only when they're
fully demented that their family takes
them to the doctor and then they get
diagnosed it's too late so the whole
point I was trying to figure out how
could you do something at home so you
could actually track your cognitive
state so that you know yeah I just take
it once every three months or tablet
things he tells you take your brain
check and you know when you're starting
to turn the corner and we're now working
with hospital systems to use this so
that everyone who comes in gets the app
and then yeah everyone takes the app
every few months and then the hospital
pings you if something's going wrong no
you I think you said these words that
within the school system or within the
school system something that five words
is create your own thing create your own
thing know it's forward its forwards and
that it's so applicable I think is that
once you've once you're learning create
your own thing go through that process
of creativity that can be so crucial for
that for the child to figure out exactly
what they care about in the world and
keep building and playing with tangibly
you in your book the boy species this
one is in runaway species easier
bending breaking blending you're talking
abut and yeah just unpack I know you do
that in a lot of your in your videos
online but just to just print the
principle of how the one second version
of it which is the idea has a genealogy
we got so fascinating as well we don't
think about that too often is that
you're looking at a chair but there has
been just thousands of years of people
figuring out how to build chairs and
then you just tweaking it ever so
slightly with this bending breaking
blending and this happens for every
single idea that we see around us yeah
you pretty much said it yeah yeah yeah
I'll say if you said it the romanticized
idea that we all have that there ideas
that come out of the blue like like when
Steve Jobs announced the iPhone there
was a reporter there who announces the
Jesus phone because it seemed to have an
immaculate conception but but in fact
the iPhone has a long history IBM put
out the ibn Simon in 1993 which was a
touch screen cell phone so you know all
these ideas there's a very clear analogy
you can trace this is true of every
great piece of art every piece of
literature and so on what we do is we
are these vessels of our particular
space and time in the world so you know
you're born in whatever year and you
just absorb the world in where you you
know South Dakota like that's what you
absorbs and as a result you know if you
just look at something like why why was
18th century American music so different
than 18th century Japanese music and
18th century
you know Kenyan music it's not that any
of those musicians couldn't have played
what the other ones were playing on
there but it wouldn't make any sense
them because we are we are the results
of our culture where all the stuff we
absorb we then all the ideas that come
in we smash them together and remix them
and do other things but but there's this
spectrum between novelty and familiarity
that's required for something to stick
in our culture so if I come up with a
piece of music that's so familiar then
it sounds like everything else that
won't stick and I come up with something
that's so novel that's completely crazy
no one gets it it won't stick so so all
artists have to find themselves in this
range you never know where it is you
have to sort of feel out the border of
what's possible but we're things AB this
balance of novelty and familiarity but
that's why cultures go off in different
directions in different places you know
that that idea are you so interesting
and then one I want to see what your
perspective is on this because I've kind
of asked you about this and it's this
new part of this sort of way that I'm
perceiving the way that we can mold
minds into the world is and maximize
their potential we we were talking about
the way that the neural infrastructure
of a child builds out from birth until
about two years of age and that I'm
curious from your perspective do you
find any any specific knowledge or
specific networks of people that you
would say are really important to get
into a child's mind at a very young age
to maximize potential I happen to be a
real cyber optimist on this point which
is I think despite all the complaints
going on we are living in such a
terrific era where I think it's
inevitable that the next generation is
gonna be a lot smarter than we are and
the reason is I'm a little bit older
than you are but you know when I was
growing up if you wanted to know
something you know my mom would have to
drive me down to the library and I'd go
to the Encyclopedia Britannica and hope
the article was not too outdated and so
on just the fact that kids were going up
with Wikipedia or being able to you know
run simulations like Nehru coast was
ck-12 and so on you know and and a
million things like dozen Khan Academy
and so on fact the kids are able to say
oh I'm curious about this and then just
get the best of me of humankind's
knowledge at this moment right there and
the best possible present I mean look I
run insist I remember thirteen year olds
all the time you see something super
smart and I say yes they say oh I saw it
on a TED talk and I think that's where
we grew up in in Albuquerque or in South
Dakota it's like you were stuck with
whatever homeroom teacher you had who
might really stink as a home disease and
but now you get the best person in the
world giving the best talk in their life
in 16 minutes you know here it is the
and you watch it with great slides
anyway the point is the opportunity to
put things together is orders of
magnitude above what we grew up with and
that's what I think is gonna make the
next generation so much smarter the
other thing to dimension that's
important is that we all grew up with I
mean I know some people here are young
we all grew up with just encase
knowledge like just in case you ever
need to know these 10 facts in Mongolian
history I'm going to teach them to you
but what you had to memorize the seven
digit phone number yeah or a ten digit
number that's that's a but but but I'm
talking about knowledge like just in
case you need to know this fact about
how this works or this thing in
chemistry or physics forever like I'm
going to teach you because you might
need it at some point but what kids are
grown up with now is is just-in-time
knowledge where as soon as they're
curious about something they look it up
and there it is and they run the
simulation they see whatever they get to
step inside of an atom or a solar system
or whatever they're interested in at
that moment and it turns out from a
neuroplasticity point of view from what
you know causes changes in the brain you
need the right cocktail of
neurotransmitters to be present and that
is present when you are curious about
something when you are curious hey how
does this work or how does this new type
of paint work or how does whatever then
then when you get the answer in the
context of your curiosity then it sticks
and you remember it that helps with the
continuity of learning then we when
you're curious you get the information
exactly yeah
so you're cyber optimist in that sense
is there is there some sort of
information or knowledge or people
networks that you think are crucial for
that for maybe even every like
objectively children should be learning
about this like language other thoughts
like an interesting question there's a
very you know coming accidents point
about everyone is super different on the
inside kids from a very young age have
totally different interests and what's
super cool where we're heading towards
rapidly with no one in steering the ship
we're heading towards is having like the
world's knowledge online but you can get
in there with whatever you're interested
if you love baseball or you love
dancing or you love whatever you know
surfing or whatever you can say you know
gosh what what what what does RBE mean
in baseball or how do i optimize the way
I get on the wave or what is this thing
there are really ways to get into the
world's knowledge and then you're in
there and you're following your own
interests so I actually think the
diversity of ways to get into the sphere
of human knowledge is is what's key and
we've achieved that accidentally do you
think that with the proliferation of
exponential technology that it becomes
information transfer mimetics becomes
more important than genetics yes and
that actually has been true for our
species for a long time now yeah we're
you know as soon as you drop into the
world you're learning everything about
your culture but but increasingly you
know about okay what is every very
clever thing that's happened in science
up to this moment okay cool and so then
we just come in at such a level ahead of
where for example Albert Einstein came
in because we because now you can read
all of mine so you can read it on
Wikipedia and get kind of understanding
of it and then your that's where you're
starting at the age of nine or something
you wrote this and I think I've heard it
a couple times prior to this as well as
that there are three times that you die
when your body stops functioning when
you're physically get buried in the
grave and then when the last person says
your name for the last time and that
yeah it is literary fiction that I wrote
yeah just to be yeah I wasn't proposing
as a scientific day it was just it was a
piece of thing I've heard that as like
death in that sense and so maybe this
sort of prior to death if you can pass
80 years in the developed world or
depending life extension technology 120
years or however long it may be if you
can potentially spread as much knowledge
or wisdom or utility or happiness or by
whatever measure you want through
civilization
you can potentially prioritize mimetics
prioritize this sort of knowledge
transfer rather than prioritize having a
child or two children or three children
but but I'm not saying they have to be
so binary lead away bifurcated in that
sense they do
need to be but now people are starting
to see in way especially Millennials Gen
Z are weighing out having families away
later if they even choose that families
they want to make more impact in the
world you think about that yeah I mean
that seems reasonable that you can leave
your your mark on the world and whatever
way you want to yeah I mean you know for
better or worse we are victims of our
evolutionary psychology which is to say
we come to the table so wired to believe
certain things are true like you know
that poop smells bad and that apple pie
smells good and that you know the you
know other people's sexual organs that
you didn't care about it all for your
first 13 years are suddenly the most
interesting world and and certain things
feel great but like all that stuff has
just carved into your psychology you you
you have no choice but to but to think
and believe that anyway so having
children is one of those things and
people find all kinds of ways to to get
around that and you know to supersede
that but it's quite natural to have
there was also another one of the
studies where they were observing the
male's as they were observing females
and they were choosing females that had
larger dilated pupils and you weren't
even conscious of you being sexually
aroused and stimulated by that or not I
want to I want to touch on some ethical
concerns I think these are very
interesting what are your thoughts about
exponential technology exacerbating
wealth inequality and how do we
ameliorate that we'll see what happens
but I think one of the advantages of
exponential technology is that price
gets driven down things that just
cheaper cheaper so just by way of
example because I'm wearing this you
know the only option for a deaf person
is a cochlear implant which is a hundred
thousand bucks this is you know this is
150 bucks yeah and so what that means is
for the world population of deaf people
now they can do something about it but
this is one story of a thousand stories
like that where things just become cheap
and easy quite Universal basic income to
like unleash people's creativity and
things like that I want to understand
that better I
I have friends were in favor of that
what I'm not clear on is if everyone
gets this wide the prices of everything
won't just won't just go back up a
little bit to essentially cancel it out
maybe there's create arguments I'd love
to talk to people about that afterwards
but I think just generally with
technology and we've already seen this
right most of the world has toilets now
most of the world surprisingly has
cellphones now and you guys know this
but like the countries that couldn't
afford personal computers and so on had
just left frogged that era leapfrogged
that area to get cell phones now it's
yeah so anyway the point is as things
yes technology races forward it just
makes the whole world all all ships rise
on that tide and I think you also said
that it's companies like kernel and
neural Inc are those are very far away
because it's gonna be difficult to get
like a neurosurgeon to want to connect
you to the Internet in that sense it's
it's a tough we we currently do see like
neural prosthetics where you can plug
into the motor cortex someone that's
paralyzed can use a robotic arm to go
and grab things and shake people's hands
and feed themselves and that's very
fascinating really important but you do
think that super instant super
intelligence is quite far away but we
can potentially do these augmentations
to our intelligence that are
non-invasive in the meanwhile as we get
there do you what I guess I want to know
more about this like this kind of like
that you don't necessarily think that
super intelligence is is that big do you
think it might be for your children and
then if that's you know further down the
line you mean the question of whether AI
will become an existential threat to us
that kind of thing yeah yeah I'm not
particularly worried about it at least
at the moment and you're asking me again
in 10 years or 50 years but I feel like
AI right now as everyone here knows it
can be super impressive things but it's
extraordinarily narrow yeah and you know
a three-year-old child is so much
smarter in other ways like being able to
you know navigate a complex room or
navigate social conversations or do a
million things will figure out how to
use a toy or whatever the
as you probably know if you take you
know a um convolutional neural network
and you train it up to be unbelievably
good at distinguishing dog pictures and
cat pictures then you try to train it to
then you say okay now just English you
know camels from penguins or whatever
it'll fail catastrophic but you have to
train it completely over again and
people are working on this issue okay
how can you actually make it so that it
will generalize and so on but the fact
is that the smartest neural nets are
nowhere near as smart as a
three-year-old and so I don't have any
worries about that the idea that the
neural network would come up with the
desire to take over the world to do
whatever the thing is and then come up
with the smarts so that we don't just
you know unplug it or whatever the thing
is seems very far-fetched to me yeah I
think that we might have some of that as
a pressing concern I think rightfully so
it's talking about the ethical concerns
like geopolitically is I think very
important so that we don't enter an arms
race
we don't enter a robotic weaponry race
either
I'm afraid that's too late I mean all
governments are putting tons of money
into any company that comes to the
Pentagon or the different military says
we do AI but there's tons of money going
into that so unfortunately that's too
late I just really look it is really
important to have those ethical
conversations just because if it's if
we're already saying that we are in an
arms race then it's it's dif difficult
to non envision a potential third world
war I mean we got if we got to figure
out how to work together and that's us
to prevent that there's there's um let's
chat in just a little bit on one there's
a couple really pressing issues towards
the end that yeah towards towards the
end we will we will just check to check
out these couple things that already
exist with the future of brain stuff
this stuff's really cool so we got we
were talking about being having a neural
prosthetic and being able to move your
hand for paralyzed you brain
preservation through cryonics we have
about a hundred thirty probably even
more people that are currently just
freezing themselves and hopes that at
one day they can be brought back to life
the connectome is happening right now so
you're taking these very tiny tiny
slices of the brain and then mapping out
and trying to create a three-dimensional
restructure it's like a zettabyte of
data per
which is as much data that's currently
on the planet which is now it's now a
quarter of our computational capacity
yeah quarter and then there's the Blue
Brain Project which is simulating an
entire brain eventually we might be able
to leave these brains and go and travel
the solar system go back and different
realities is such exciting stuff fly
live underwater okay in some you
basically what I what I really loved
about some was that you pretty much took
simulated universes or simulated worlds
and you ran us through like what would
it be like if you lived your life in
Reverse what would it be like if you
were born a different gender what would
it be like if you were multi-dimensional
if you had experienced everything in
batches so if you had to live for 30
sleep for 30 years and then if you had a
like what was it sit on the toilet for
how long five months have seven months
of sex these very interesting sort of
tales that you told and I think that
what you do when you do that is you
creatively stimulate other people to get
outside of our sort of the normal the
normative landscape of our world and I
love that about your mind and the way
that you teach and was that kind of like
your intention was to just yeah I just
expand our horizon I think that science
and literature are essentially trying to
get it the same thing it's but but to my
mind literature picks up where science
leaves off which is past the realm of
the things we can test that's the wrong
letter sure you say okay look what if
this what if that the only difference is
that in science you ask what if what if
and then you try to test them so anyway
that's yeah that was just my more
speculative version of of the same kind
of thing but really that's all that we
ever do in the laboratory is think wait
yeah we all grew up thinking this but
what if it's this other thing and then
that's progress when it's right
yeah and that reminds me a lot of the
idea of why we called the show
simulation in many ways is because we
like to expand people's minds to what it
would be like to live in simulated
realities or on other rocks orbiting
stars with different sort of
gravitational poles different evolution
timelines different amount of energy
that's being given to the planet from
the star all this sort of the similar
sort of idea now you're like this is a
collector a collector is kind of like a
simulator in a census you're running
these simulations and you're
understanding what's happening in the
simulations we do love to ask the
question about if you think that we're
alone in the cosmos or not what do you
think about that um
I mean I think exactly what all
astrophysicists think about this which
is that it seems so terribly unlikely
that we're alone and yet it's so weird
that nobody we haven't heard a peep so
we're just stuck in this paradoxical
silence but from just from the point of
view of a biologist the general view on
biology is that if you take a rock and
you simmer it at the right distance from
a star long enough you get you know
sprouts with life right we've got all
kinds of life forms on this planet so
it's very strange to think that that
would be happening everywhere do you
think that we live in a simulation so
this is some this is actually a very old
idea many of you probably know Rene
Descartes was one who asks this question
he said how do I know that I'm not just
a brain-in-a-vat being stimulated by
scientists to feel like I'm sitting in a
chair and I'm having a conversation and
so on and his conclusion was that you
can't really know that and so he made a
very important step in philosophy where
he said as you're Paul Stokes you're
sweet I think therefore I am and what he
meant is there's somebody asking this
question there's somebody asking this
question of a Mayan brain-in-a-vat and
so so I exist whether I'm a brand Nevada
I'm me or whatever there's something me
that's there so that was an important
step but but the question whether a
simulation that you know that was sort
of I would say that was sort of buried
in philosophy departments for a while
but now just now especially in Silicon
Valley that's becoming a really
interesting question because we can
build simulations that are so detailed
and terrific so it seems of course you
know totally plausible that a future
civilization is building a simulation
where you seem like you're in this very
beautiful room and you're talking with
people and yeah and and it would
you mean that hard to simulate this
especially if there's nothing going on
outside like in other words your house
is not being simulated right now none of
the details but as soon as you stepped
outside then the street gets stimulated
again and so on none of the earth is
rendered exact area of the earth that
you are in this renders exact and that
was one of my stories and some actually
is that only the rendering happens where
you're seeing it yeah but the point is
that's various you could run that almost
on a cell phone and so that's why this
idea has been taking more and more
seriously as a possibility now the
question is how would we ever get it out
of the realm of a philosophical question
into a scientific one we don't know the
answer to that yet unless there's a
particular sign like one of the
transistors and the simulation burns out
and suddenly you know like all the
plants disappear or something it might
be deja vu it might be something really
yeah I don't really buy deja vu is the
thing that check this out well virtual
reality extrapolated a hundred years
completely indistinguishable urine is
jumping into the world it only takes you
your body only to do lives ten seconds
but you live 80 years in the virtual
world and so you completely forget that
you're in the virtual world and you're
just living in it and then you're done
and then you just jump into the next
simulation whatever you want I mean
that's not really that far away I think
I'll be able to experience that sometime
in my life in those simulated worlds and
I'll be able to design simulated worlds
I'll be able to go and observe what how
the earth has evolved how other planets
have evolved around stars go and jump
between them that kind of stuff
the only question is whether you could
actually experience the 80 years in ten
seconds you probably couldn't because
because you are a big giant creature
who's made up of these trillions of
cells and that means your time runs at a
certain pace and so yeah shove
information in there that fast yeah so
last question what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
love drinks maybe that would be right I
mean obviously I think its context is
because we're talking about this you
know the scientific pursuit meaning just
trying to figure out what is going on
around us because
as relates to this issue of whether
we're in a simulation like you don't
really remember getting here as far as
you know you just sort of always been an
existing creature like you don't
remember turning on as such and and
you're told that someday you will not be
here anymore but we have a very poor
understanding of how we got here we're
just sort of oh yeah oh here I am and
and we're just surrounded by massive
mysteries like the size of the cosmos
the fact that is there life you know the
fact we haven't been contacted by anyone
and so but but even very basic mysteries
like you know in my very narrow study
about the brain it's all mysteries like
how is consciousness produced how do you
put together you know billions of
neurons that get this private subjective
experience what is why do we sleep at
night why do we shut off what is what is
intelligence any measure why do we have
emotions no but there's a million
questions and so the scientific pursuit
is a way of saying okay look I'm gonna
think about a possible answer this
question and I'm gonna test it and five
other people are gonna think of other
possible answers we're all gonna fight
and debate in the literature and and
we're gonna say hey wow there's
something that none of us thought of and
so as a civilization we're creeping
forward that way but it's very new like
the last several hundred years is really
what we've been the time that we've
started doing that systematically so
it's a very beautiful time that we're in
it gives us a better more strong real
lens to observe reality with yeah over
time yeah yeah or a more confusing one
and so we're confusing right if you grew
up a thousand years ago and you were
told look here's the scoop Jesus this is
that whatever fine it's pretty easy to
understand now we write giant but I mean
there's this book at our field called
principles of neural science which is
that big and you know my joke on it is
that it's it's not it shouldn't be
called principles of neuroscience cuz if
it were principles it would be like the
size of that am flitters yeah but the
bit but the fact is just a core dump of
all our knowledge but the point is with
as we get more and more and more
knowledge about everything it's it gets
more and more confusing I mean it took
me seven years to write this corner
lose that much data out there yeah so
anyway it may not make it clearer to us
what our reality is but at least it's
navigating in a long way that's testable
and yeah well David Eagleman a man of so
many different talents and knowledge
--is and wisdoms that have been
communicated through all these different
books as well as now an entrepreneur
helping people that are deaf new neo
sensory making new senses brain check
continuing to profess as well and just
being a major influence through media
and culture on our lives inspiring the
next generation thank you so much for
joining us on the show Thank You Alan
such a pleasure thank you
really great
[Applause]